Hello, Rob. Hello, Max.
Good morning. How are you?
Morning.
I'm good, how are you?
Doing alright.
So, that's a happy Monday.
Happy Monday, for sure.
So far, yeah.
Yeah, back from long weekend, eh?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's nice to get away.
So, how was it? Good? Spend time with family.
Yeah, spent time with family, went to a parade.
Nice, nice.
Yeah, relaxed a little bit.
Yeah, it's good.
I fought back 50 years worth of IV growth from the corners of my property.
Oh, man.
See.
Um...
I'm just waiting for Ashish to join. Let's give him a minute.
Okay.
And then we can start.
Is Aman still recovering? Aman still recovering? Excuse me.
Yeah, yeah. He's back from the surgery and he's just resting up a little bit more.
So...
Yeah.
He's resting up for this week and will be back in action from next Monday.
Cool.
Morning, Rog. Morning, Max. How are you?
Ashish.
Morning, morning.
Yep.
Morning.
Okay.
Alright, so how are things going with Sterling?
Still going well for me. He is continuing to push forward on the work that he has been assigned. He's been working on large e-mail migration project for us, and it's been going well. I've also got him scoping out another one.
Mhm.
So we're keeping him busy. I've got a couple of trainings that I'm going to be hoping to assign for him this next week that I can get onto his plate so that I can have him also aware of the methodology that we're trying to use for our project management. So that'll be really important once I get those available. Rob, I think you said that that was probably going to be near the end of the week. We would get him access to some of those.
Hopefully sooner, but yeah, a request has been made.
Okay.
Yeah, and then that's, what would you say, like 5 hours or less of modules?
If he does all of them, he really only needs to focus on the one that's PE related, and then you can decide which ones you want to include them in. Beyond that.
Yeah.
Okay.
probably 3-ish hours then within the professional services department.
In the long term, I have some other goals, but those are like very stretch goalie kind of things within that tool. But yeah, we'll get him trained into this. I believe you guys are having him work on a Microsoft certification too.
Okay.
Yes, yes, he's focusing on MS102 and yeah.
So, Rob, I just wanna...
Any, any timeframe?
OK.
Yep, sorry, go ahead.
Any time frame on that Ms. 102?
Yep, so he's going through the trainings of Ms. 102 as of yet. Once he's done with the trainings, he'll be able to complete the certification. So I believe it will take around two to three weeks more for him to complete the certification.
OK, and he he's doing the refresher stuff right, 'cause he he felt he already knew the content, OK?
Yeah, yeah.
Yes.
Kip.
That still feels like a pretty reasonable amount of time for Ms. Cert.
And.
That's right. Yep. And I just wanted to have a quick check around the pricing for MS102 certification. I hope the cost is covered with this one strategy. Okay.
They are dance.
Yeah, yeah, we'll cover it. It's...
All right.
100 something dollars, right?
Yep, so whatever pause would be there, we'll obviously let you know. And so I'm not sure if Aman had a conversation around this with you in the past, did he?
Regarding the certification.
At.
Yeah, we, we have conversations about it.
Okay.
And yeah, and we're happy to cover the cost.
The way we work it internally is we'll pay for the certification once the technician passes it.
Right.
Yep, yep, this is this is how it goes. So, once Sterling clears the certification, we will let you know, and we will let you know the amount that he paid at the fees, and we can continue with the reimbursement then. So, Rob, is it possible for you to just send an e-mail to Kip, myself, and Aman?
Ketan.
OK.
So that, you know, it is documented and for the record purpose, I can have my e-mail address entered into the chat so that we have it handy.
Okay, please do. Yeah, no problem.
Any other business?
No, I guess this is all we have for today. If you have something for us, Rob.
I don't. I'm Max.
Nothing at this time. No, everything seems like it's going pretty well. Get out of here.
Yep, so I just wanna I have a quick question.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I just have a quick question. So based on my discussion with Sterling, most of the time that he's spending on the project that contributes to the non-billable. So is this how it's going to be or it's going to change after some time?
T.
He's currently working on an internal project for us, so a lot of that time is non-billable. And we're also currently working on our project methodology. So I'm trying to capture all of the time that goes into projects so that we can get metrics on what percentage we are not billing for. And then I'll bring it back to our VCAOs to try to increase the.
The.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good morning.
percentage. I know he's spending a lot of time training right now, but the goal is to get his billing utilization up. I'm just trying to build a framework for that to work.
Yeah.
Okay, sure, sure.
Yeah, it was it was just good circumstances where we knew he would have cycles as he's training up and we needed it done, so...
Hoh.
That was planned. It's not a normal.
It's giving me some practice, managing him and him some practice working in our environments. So it's pretty good.
All part of the transition, may I see it?
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, so from the next call onwards, we will be presenting his data in terms of his utilization and including both billable, non-billable, and the tickets he works on, how many he worked and how many he's closed, and also whatever.
the updates on the account, like the things, the projects he's been working on, the trainings, we will be able to present all that information in a presentation, in a deck. So in a more structured way, so it'll be easier for us to track things down, like how things are progressing and how.
but we need any areas of improvement and everything.
Okay, that sounds great.
Yeah, yeah. Ashish, anything from you?
Nope.
Nope, I'm all set. Thank you so much.
Okay, great. Thank you everyone for joining this call. And again, we don't have to wait for this call. In between anything you want to share, any feedback, feel free to e-mail us. Me, Ashish and Aman, and we'll be more than happy to help.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Max. Thank you, Rob. Thank you, Clay.
Sounds good. Thanks, guys.
Thank you so much, gentlemen.
Blake.
Bye.